[موسيقى]
حيوانات حيوانات بين الناس وفي الغابات
تعطي جمالا للحياه يا لا جمال الكائنات
تعطي جمالا للحياه يا جمال
[موسيقى]
الكائنات بسياح دوما صداح اقذ في كل صباح
بسياح دوما صداح اقذ في كل صباح لهيبتي
بين الطيور انا الديك المحبوب يا صاح
لهيبتي بين الطيور انا الديك المحبوبه يا
صاح ا للبشر انا اغلى صديق لي صوت ويسمى
نهيق للبشر انا اغلى صديق لي صوت ويسمى
نهيق مشهور ادعى الحمار للجهد وللتعبير
مشهور ادعى الحمار للجهد وللتعبير
[موسيقى]
هنا وهناك انط والعب طول نهار انا لا اتعب
هنا وهناك انط نط والعب طول نهار انا لا
اتعب انظر ما احلى اذني محبوب واسمى
الارنب انظر ما احلى اذني محبوب واسمى
[موسيقى]
الارنب حيوانات حيوانات بين الناس وفي
الغابات حيوانات حيوانات بين الناس وفي
الغابات تعطي جمالا للحياه يا لا جمالي
للكائنات تعطي جمالا للحياه لا جمال
[موسيقى]
الكائنات انا المعزه قد جئت الان تميزني
عده الوان انا المعزه قد جئت الان تميزني
عده الوان فقمي رشيق وقوي واعطيكم اشهل
البان فقمي رشيق وقوي واعطيكم اشهى
الالبان
وانا سفينه الصحراء هناك اعيش بدون عناء
جمل ويميز ني سنامي وايضا بالصبر عن الماء
جمل ويميز ني سنامي وايضا بالصبر عن
الماء لي منقار اعرض اطول طيبه القلب انا
الاجمل لي من قار اعرض اطول طيبه القلب
انا الاجمل انا بطه اسبح في البركه وبها
اقضي وقتا افضل انا بطا اسبح في البركه
وبها اقضي وقتا
[موسيقى]
افضل حيوانات حيوانات بين الناس وفي
الغابات حيوانات حيوانات بين الناس وفي
الغابات تعطي جمالا للحياه يا لا جمال
الكائنات تعطي جمالا للحياه يا لا جمال
الكائنات